hello everyone and a very warm welcome
in joining us for the president's design
award 2020 recipients forum part 1
creating a better world by design
designing with and for communities my
name is audrey lim and i will be your mc
for today
the president's design award or dpa for
short is singapore's highest accolade
for designers and designs across all
disciplines
organized by the design singapore
council and the urban redevelopment
authority this is the 13th cycle of the
award
on the 30th june 11 recipients were
presented with their awards during the
pda 2020 awards ceremony
in the first of the two-part series
today's recipients forum features six of
the president's design awards 2020
recipients
they all share how their awarded
projects and body of work have
transformed and impacted the lives of
people from all walks of life from the
very young to the elderly to
multi-generational families and
marginalized communities
before we delve into the session proper
i'd like to highlight a couple of house
rules just to keep today's session
running as smoothly as possible
please be informed that this webinar
will be recorded and that your
microphones will be automatically set on
mute throughout the session
we most definitely welcome questions
during the q a segment and you may
submit these questions through the zoom
q a function
should you encounter any technical
issues please reach out to our technical
team through the zoom chat function
last but not least this forum will be
accredited two cpd points for those of
you who would like to apply for cpd
points do fill in the details required
in the survey form at the end of the
forum
without further ado let's welcome
architect larry young prize secretary
for the lee kuan yew world city prize
commissioner general for singapore
pavilion at dubai world expo 2020
registrar board of architects to say a
few words
thank you audrey
well distinguished speakers who are our
most distinguished pda recipients
for 2020
ladies and gentlemen a very good
afternoon to all of you
and for those that are joining us from
europe
america
asia and even asean a very good day to
all of you and hope you enjoyed the
session today
welcome and thank you for joining us
online
first time i think we're doing that
because of kobe 19
for the part one of the president's
design award 2020 recipients forum
this forum is organized for the public
and the design community to find out
more about the inspiration and thinking
behind the designers and designs awarded
in the 2020
design award
and how good architecture and design
have the power
to shape the society we live in
over the years the stature of the award
has grown as design becomes increasingly
important to singapore as a driver of
innovation
the award honors the significant
achievements and contributions
of the nation's design talents
who managed to push boundaries
to create innovative and impactful
solutions
that address local and global issues
such as the asian societies
underserved communities
sustainability and climate change
etc this cycle of pda
saw the designer of the year category
been awarded to two designers
and the designs of the year category
designs
the quality of our home-grown designs
is getting increasingly sophisticated
our designers are also well placed to
create works and transcend cultures
promote sustainability
and resolve contextual challenges in
meaningful ways
today
we have six recipients
four from the architecture discipline
and two from the design discipline
they will be sharing their design
philosophies
creative processes
they are challenges and how they have
overcome them
through this sharing
i hope you all will gain a deeper
understanding
and appreciation of the transformative
role of design on communities
as well as the impact
that these innovative designs
have in adding vibrancy to the built
environment and in improving people's
lives
i also hope that this forum
will inspire all of us towards
architecture and design
excellent i will now hand the time back
to audrey to introduce the speakers and
please
have a pleasant afternoon
over to you audrey
thanks for that architect larry it's now
my pleasure to introduce the president's
design awards 2020 recipients on our
panel today
designer of the year recipients
architect coo bing ping and architect
belinda huang directors arc studio
architecture and urbanism private
limited
design of the year recipient cloister
house represented by architect alan tay
and architect sito kamloon principal
partners formworks architects
design of the year recipient sparkle
tots large preschool at pongol
represented by architect ho zhu yin
founding partner and managing director
lord architects
design of the year recipient atania
green school represented by mr prasun
kumar co-founder brilli billion brics
limited
design of the year recipient good life
makan represented by architect sia chi
huang chief executive officer dp
architects private limited
design of the year recipient kampung
admiralty represented by architect paul
chi director wohar architects private
limited
let's welcome our first pair of speakers
architect ku bing ping and architect
belinda huang to kick off the session
the duo founded ark studios in 1999
and since then have scaled new heights
with their high rise high density and
award-winning developments such as
pinnacle at daxton and the tombusu
today they will share how the power of
architecture can better humankind and
create environments that promote
hospitality
architect architect huang over to
you
thank you thanks audrey hi everyone
our sharing today is called the
architecture of our common home
planet earth being our only home this
picture shows everything we love the sun
the blue skies and sea
with the wooden handmade jetty and in
the background you can see our family
as designers we ask ourselves a lot of
questions
chiefly how do we strive
a tribe as a human race in a safe and
just world this is our twin challenge
today environmental restoration and
social justice how can we ensure social
justice and restore our environment at
the same time what does it mean to be
human and how can we have enough food
for all without cutting down the very
forest that produces oxygen and water
for us the kovic pandemic challenge has
affected all of us it is not the only
pandemic in history and yet we have
never been more interconnected and
interdependent
kovit has exaggerated the social
ruptures in our society can architecture
be designed to heal
our climate became stable only about 11
000 years ago allowing culture to form
and only about 100 years ago that we
were able to thrive with the rise of
technology with the atomic bomb we gain
the power to destroy ourselves and
geologists start to call this a new
epoch anthropocene where human beings is
able to affect geological time how do we
navigate into safe anthropocene
avoiding the rupture
ping big and i sat down during the
circuit breaker to just examine
ourselves and to realign our mission and
purpose
inspired by the japanese concept of
ikigai this diagram shows how we try to
bring our projects as close as possible
to the intersection of four circles our
values what we believe
our expertise what we are good at what
the world needs and how the projects are
financed
hospitality is our first value we love
how harry now and puts it hospitality is
the creation of free space where
strangers enter to become friends
in this picture on the right we hosted a
workshop in cambodia with the students
whom we were designing for
our architects told us that the students
blessed them with joy and gave them
meaning in their work
love and justice goes hand in hand we
see love as an action and as a
relationship we see justice as
restorative and not punitive
it is not to punish but to protect and
to restore peace order
love is interesting because it is not
something we can ask for or something we
can store up for later it is something
that we have to give away in order for
us to receive the more we give the more
we receive
connection
we believe that we are all made to
connect
for that we need vulnerability we like
brene brown's definition where a
connection exists when we derive
sustenance and strength from the
relationship
we strive to create spaces of connection
with ourselves with others with nature
and with the divine
what are some key guiding principle for
us we have seven
first we align all our projects to the
current esg paradigm
the united nations sustainable
development goal has
the first four goals zero poverty zero
hunger health for all and quality
education is woven as much as possible
into our practice
we try to think in cycles and in in
circular in a circular manner we are
very happy that the latest version of gm
2021 has aligned itself with the unsdg
and other globe global goals and at the
bottom left is kate ravers donut economy
the outer ring describes the nine
planetary boundaries
which we have to keep within to keep our
planets safe and the inner ring is the
social foundation
provision of food education and water
for all
ecology means more than just
forests and animals it also means human
relationships and organizations
understanding cultural ecology is
critical as history and culture is alive
and ever evolving the first thing we did
for our rwanda project was to visit the
genocide museum to feel and to cry with
the people like to immerse ourselves we
have dialogues listening deeply to the
words and to the hearts of the people as
designers we learn to encourage and to
empower local communities
we understand that the quality of daily
life is not something that we can impose
from the outside but understood within
the world of symbols and customs
we draw from various disciplines
including social sciences and
neuroscience
our designs try to integrate as many
different contexts as possible
we strive for a beauty beyond just the
material but also the beauty of trust of
care of peace and of connection
how attractive are those cities in their
architectural design when they are full
of spaces which connect relate and favor
the recognition of others
as designers we learn to find our
authentic self so that we can be fully
present with humility
every person on earth has an inalienable
right to his or her integral development
when we lose respect for the human
person we lose the social peace
stability and security provided by a
certain order that looks after the
common good in our present global
society injustice and basic human rights
declaration still abounds
the principle of common good is a call
to reach out to the last and the least
as architects and designers how can we
respond more to what the world needs and
less to what the world pays
our world is a gift we have freely
received and must share with others we
cannot view our world as a utilitarian
means to profit the individual
we realize that intergenerational
solidarity and unity is not an option
we cannot just borrow and take without
consideration for what we leave for
future generations
how do we respect justice between
generations in our work
we talk we share we create experiences
and connections between generations
as designers we seek to see
see beyond just space but also across
time as architects we embrace a
human-centered approach that requires us
to empty ourselves and fill the space
with promise to ignite hearts and to see
the eyes of the people around us shine
with hope we look at the entire
experience from our first conversation
to the process of building and conflict
resolution
our aim is to create architecture that
integrates nature and technology we see
technology as a tool in the service of
integral ecology and we see design as
research where we are learning doing and
seeing at the same time
computational tools are used to help us
help us to deal with more and more data
and to help us to see with other lenses
and in many different ways
opening up for us ever greater
possibilities and prospects
our integrated process has four stages
that mimic design thinking methods
discovering with compassion defining
mindfully developing joyfully and
delivering with gratitude
it is not always easy we constantly have
to reflect and examine where we have
fallen off the circle and constantly
find ourselves climbing back on
but to us our work is love made visible
and what does it mean to work with love
it is to build a house with affection
even as if your beloved were to dwell in
that house
our ark studio journey started with the
design of single family homes we love
our homes
to be orderly calm open filled with
natural light and air and surrounded by
nature
as our projects grew in complexity we
learned to express the desires of our
clients
the house on the top is a home for
collector for a collector we turn his
collection into a facade and the house
below
expresses the preference of the husband
for more rectilinear forms and the wife
for more curry linear forms
single homes become high-density
high-rise collective homes the
pinnacle-like dustin has stood the test
of time and was recently awarded the
ctbuh 10-year excellence award for
sustainability and social impact
of the project was precast including the
sky bridges we continue to explore
technology to create identity we strive
to use simple rules to create complex
results and finding intelligent
solutions to complex problems after
completing the pinnacle duxton we
curated this exhibition together with
nus and made this provocative statement
1000 singapores can house the entire
world population using only
0.5
of the earth's land area super small
that's equivalent to one france
or two japans very tiny footprint
we brought a 1 000 scale model of
singapore to venice
imagine the entire section of an entire
nation
in a pavilion we believe that singapore
is a living laboratory for compact
cities of the world cities with the
smallest possible ecological footprint
every project in singapore therefore
makes a difference to this conversation
in kolkata we attended weddings learned
baths too and visited homes to
understand how to design bungles in the
air the cloud form is a reference to
tagore's daya a cloud pregnant with
promise
the tembusu draws inspiration from the
origins of wing thai as a garment
factory drapery strings and lightness
with themes woven together in the
tapestry of sky gardens and ecology
in sentosa the sea and the fluid lines
of waves and kelp forest help us to
design
an 800 room hotel over a bus terminus
the environmental deck is a waterscape
of pools of different age groups and
multiple users from sunbathing to a
stage for music and even a fashion show
right next door sharing the same compact
service network is a restoration project
what was once military use for
surveillance of the sea lanes is now a
luxury hotel for private getaways what
was once a parade square for soldiers
now holds wedding matches from hostility
to hospitality a project riding on the
waves of spirodynamic development the
next project is in the highlands of
malaysia and it has taught us all about
biodiversity and the forest we learned
from the indigenous tribes from
permaculture and learned about
protecting our natural capital how do we
develop a new town in the rural
highlands creating a new economy around
sustainability
safe farms education and tourism and yet
we grow an entire forest to restore what
was once locked before
on this columbarium project we
transformed our swans a dark and scary
space with energy wells bring natural
light gardens and water into the
basement
instead of a place to be feared and
avoided it has become a space where
people go to meditate and to contemplate
we restored the wesley methodist church
by keeping the new extensions quiet and
framing the original church we restored
the processional aisle and clarified the
original architecture in the process
forming a new dialogue between the old
and the new
in cambodia we use simple low-cost
material like
l angles and pvc tubes create a school
with a unique identity what really moved
us was how a girl was sold off to
prostitution she was later bought back
by the nuns and is now an architect
without this school many of the children
will end up after grade 6 in factories
or in the flesh trade
as architects we bring our work to make
our world a little bit better we listen
with compassion and humility becoming
more aware of ourselves and striving to
improve a little every day we create
spaces that host all and use technology
to improve daily lives we see safe safe
farms and straw being turned into
building panels rice plantation and fish
farms on rooftops a forest in a condo we
protect nature and even improve upon it
wherever we go this is our heart for our
common home as designers and as
architects thank you
thanks so much for that sharing
architect
and architect linda huang that
insightful sharing has moved all of us
next we have architect alan tay and
architect sito kamloon principal
partners of formworks architects whose
numerous projects have received critical
acclaim around the world including
awards from singapore institute of
architects the international
architecture awards and the design for
asia awards may now call upon
architect alan t to share on cloister
house a fresh and artful representation
of a courtyard house that was designed
for a family living in the tropics
architect tay over to you
hi everyone
great to be here to share our project
the twister house
yeah this is the team
beginner project is a team that is
behind this obviously there are others
iskandar i think i believe you're an
audience that has been offered
tremendous contribution to the project
but this is the threesome that
they saw it through and we have
tremendous time uh
doing a project and i'm really grateful
for that i'm here speaking because
probably i'm the fastest mouth of mount
three
uh this is the project it is jp across
the street
um on the sitting on land size of 47 000
square feet very large
piece of real estate
just to put his perspective
that's the size in comparison of the
projects of houses that we have done in
singapore
over the last two decades in
from from semi-detached to
bungalows the gcb but this is something
that we're confronted was really new and
huge we set us thinking
and in comparison skill
was that if if we were to accommodate
about
15 000 square feet of space which is
more than comfortable for the single
family
uh everything in one story this is what
it takes
on the land
and that set us thinking
that
we we begin to see and and there's
always been our dream to build a
single-story house
because of obvious reasons so it's super
universal it is accessible wherever you
are you are super connected to any part
of the house
you are next to your land you are next
to your roof as well
or the benefit of a of a single-story
house and of course with such a deep
plan
um and also part of a brief requirement
for security the idea of fortification
the idea of creating an introverted
space that's secure for kids whether
they're so young
the huskers travel quite a fair bit
that was some consideration of looking
at cod yet typology
and
and you can see normally your simple
layout will be a huge courtyard that
organized the different blocks within
the house or
we could begin to see
and visualize that would there be a
possibility of multiple quarters what
would that
engender with this
these configurations
we begin to look at
the the three projects seen from plants
or on the left is jeffy powers uh famous
the third the sorry thirteenth lane
colombo and on the right the middle is a
chrysler house plan and
the on the right is the house in bombay
which is which is the left of it
and to study really these are quiet
houses
and of course there are numerous
examples in that famous scenario and in
china
that is always kind of reference of what
could we do when we want to create this
new
tropical courtyard design
and the final result was it was 12 years
um or in green
um you have 11 chords there are smaller
that perfect throughout the main block
and the bigger one at the rear
a quick look at the plan so this is the
koia begin to organize the various
spaces
just to orientate such a complex plan
and move faster the blue zone is where
the guest rooms are to keep the housing
in-laws
on the bottom you have the staff
quarters uh really a two-bedroom
apartment with their own common spaces
living rooms quarters and and work space
the place space for the kids the
entertainment
in rate
and then these are the kids immediate
bedrooms the three sons the three kids
with the master
sharing a common space a family space
and the rest
is all common a kind of continuous
corridor
a kind of chrysler around the courtyards
about common spaces of living dining
eating
drinking
playing
and and one of the benefits of this koi
i realized is that in terms of
landscape and garden immediately could
have this domesticated
size or skill
garden that you can manage and almost
instantaneous quantification or relative
to the scale of the courtyards they
don't wait forever for them to grow
while
on the periphery we anticipate the plant
the trees will take a normal life cycle
maybe 10 to 15 years to grow so they can
come in young
and and establish themselves over time
over here are going gonna really be fast
so quick look at what it is
elevation from a street in the daytime
the roofscape rudimentary functional
because highly see from the facade all
you see is really the soffit
in the internal spaces how the courtyard
defines the various spaces with the
different variation of roof that hangs
over the spaces
i'll just go very quick
and different pockets of spaces
narrow tight interconnected
and this is the view from the back of
the bigger car you are looking back at
the main house
i'm quite fast and then i come to the
last slide i have some about 50 seconds
left
so yes this is the view of when it's at
night
oh i see that sorry
it's really fast
okay so yeah i think we'll take any
questions at the interview
or the
q a yeah
thanks for that really speedy
presentation architect alan t
uh our next speaker is architect ho zu
yin founding partner and managing
director lord architects who views
architecture as a lens through which one
understands the wider world he will
share on sparkle touch large preschool
at pongol one of the first mega child
care centers in singapore let us hear
how the unique design of the preschool
created a joyful and experiential
learning environment for the children
architect over to you
oh architect we might need you to unmute
yourself i see there you are okay you're
back
thank you
well good job ellen i'll try to do as as
well as you
five minutes okay so so um basically
when our client sparkle thoughts
approached us um they have quite a
challenging task we were assigned to
build a child care for 1 000 children
um
and
in in a period of 11 months and this for
the childcare is for kids that ranges
from
an infant to four years old so it's
really an early
years center so after five months of a
design a tenure the
project started to construct and we
managed to finish it within ten and a
half months
so just a bit of understanding before i
did childcare my simplistic
understanding of childcare was really a
place for them to play eat and sleep but
in reality it's it's actually much more
than that um we realized to design a
childcare we need to provide
when you think in terms of safety
comfort and provide a learning
environment for the very young
so what does that mean
for the very young they really learn by
play
in specifically for auditory visual
tactile learning um it is really the um
the engagement of their bodies with the
environment that they start to learn
so
these are the themes that i will touch
on brief very briefly throughout the
slides so the site is pretty much
situated in right in the middle of our
housing board estate in pongo
the immediate challenge was of course a
thousand kids you know how do you design
a child care for a thousand kids because
um this this was the first time um
something is like that is done to this
scale in singapore um we approach the
challenge by segmenting it into two
parts so it's basically around 300 each
and the center had a principle for each
so this theme of three became quite
prevalent throughout the center so there
are three principles the building is
divided into three has three cores
secondly
the idea of our trap the safety from
vehicular traffic because our worst
fears was that from seven a.m to nine
a.m
one thousand cars come and drop off
children so uh the whole building is
really designed like the island where
there are vehicle circulation and
drop-off points throughout the perimeter
that also helps to engender the circular
form
thirdly disease outbreak
as you may know
um every now and then there are
outbreaks of hand food mouth disease in
child care
so
again the center is designed to be
easily segmented such that they are
individual access on hindsight this is a
design philosophy seems precious in
terms of a covid outbreak so this is
something that we can continue to
improve for our florida child cares and
schools
next the idea the challenge of scale we
were these are very young kids from zero
to four years old we were kind of
concerned that the 40 meters diameter
will overpower them in terms of
the perception of scale and height so
in response we've broken down the whole
space into three segments again with the
multi-purpose hall right in the middle
um to further down to further bring down
the scale so this is what you see the
final building product you could see
that the whole ground floor space is
segmented into trees
each of its own theme
um
a playground for infants and cordless
water play and
the entrance
also going into the classrooms itself we
paid attention to the fact that actually
our users are really not more than a
little tall so um
sidelines
sidelines into the classrooms looking at
their friends and all that it is really
design sidelines and furniture are
really designed according to that skill
next
um the idea of environmental strategies
because we envision a place where a
child care where they can play freely
in
uh natural
air but of course sheltered from the sun
and it it is such a large space that it
will really be
energy gasoline to to air condition
whole space so what we devised was
really a high teflon roof sheltered area
but
designed to allow airflow to go through
and also augmented by hvls fans so in
the section you will see that
it's really a very light roof to let in
natural light
and ventilation
right in the middle we had this idea
that we didn't want the children to be
isolated from the environment
if it if it is a
bright sunny day that the sun should
shine right in if it's
if there's a tropical outpour
the rain should really come in so so we
managed to convince the client to leave
a big oculus right in the middle of the
of the building such that the rain comes
true so this idea of being in touch with
nature is really important for us
so the diagrams were conceived
over a few weeks and um because of the
clarity where literally in the final
plan would literally just build from the
diagram itself and you can notice that
because of the high speed of
construction all the classrooms are very
modular
the entrance for you
and this is the the entry plaza that
will greet visitors um imbued within
throughout the child care it's it's this
idea of movement and play so in every
sense of the word every corner you would
have playground or you would have a ram
that encourages children to run and play
even when um
these two slides actually at the
entrance and pickup area we thought it'd
be great you know to have slides to
occupy them while waiting for their
parents to pick them up
and
even when during dining in the dining
main dining hall you could have very
clear visibilities to the playgrounds
outside
water play
different and toddler play areas
and connecting the different flaws
instead of making them
block staircases
we actually created a circular ramp that
connects the various floors from
ground all the way up to the roof
second story
related to the idea of play and learning
it's the idea of
learning through tactile sensations so
the idea of using mosaics and using
colors to tell them different shape the
rooms of their classrooms
instead of just relying on alphabets or
names we actually created a series of
diagrams
cute little diagrams that based on
segments of circles and the idea of this
continuous spectrum of colors again
we've referenced back to the the sparkle
cost logo such that it marks and
pervades
the whole
all the whole entire ring of classrooms
and
it is brought inside the classrooms
itself so again this diagram it's not
really specific um but it does give some
suggestions of the creatures and we
think that by doing this it excites the
imagination of the children
and the color themes are brought in
through into each of the classrooms as
well
interior of classrooms
the external corridor because of the
nature of the teflon roof and the oculus
you really get a very rich play of light
and shadow and the mood
varies throughout the day
the overall view of the of the child
care center
and now we've reached the last water
roof and it is really a
tremendous big continuous circle of play
um the way we we design this
space in conjunction with our landscape
architect uh salad dressing is really to
think of it as slices of pizza
that have different flavors as you
progress along so we imagine that when
children run along the whole whole
circular ring they would they would
encounter different ways of play and
they could sample the different modes
and this will result in this um
really very vibrant vibrantly populated
runescape
so
[Music]
this is the elevation
and
i've come to my final slide so
we we
the teachers actually asked the children
during the opening ceremony to
to draw to draw a painting to give the
impression of the child care so this is
the resultant uh
painting and
basically i think they've got down
they've got the concept down to a pet
it's just circles of different colors
and and richness and and diversity and
basically that that's what we wanted to
convey um so really um to sum up
everything um what we wanted to create
was a space that a joyous space for the
children such that they will actually
look forward to coming to school um
yeah and hopefully i don't want to leave
thank you
thank you for that
thanks so much architecture our next
speaker is mr prasun kumar co-founder of
billion bricks limited mr kumar
co-founded billion bricks in 2013 as a
non-profit to solve the global housing
crisis in a completely new way today he
will share about italia green school and
how the school has created a place of
pride and dignity for this marginalized
community and catalyzed social change
over to you
hello everyone
um
there are about 2.2 billion children in
the world
who go to school
many of them study in environments that
we are very familiar with in singapore
where they have all the aids but there
are many many millions of children that
actually don't have access to those aids
they don't live in environments or study
studying environments that we or our
children are used to
their schools do not look like what you
see in the picture but instead are
somewhat like this
often
we send our children for to learn from
experiences from teachers from aids but
they have to find their own aids through
which actually they can learn
their sports happen in their refugee
camps often if that's what they're
living in
and they don't have these inspirational
school buildings that we see around us
but often it's just a tree that works as
a building for them
i founded billion bricks about six years
ago
with a mission to never design poorly
for the poor
my partner robert who's not here is
holidaying in in europe came together
with me on this journey and over the
last six years we've impacted about 15
000 lives uh through various efforts
that billion bricks has done across the
world
uh some time ago itania approached us to
design a school for about 50 000
stateless children that are in malaysia
their parents come from philippines and
indonesia to work deep inside oil palm
plantations which you and i are all
familiar with in some form or the other
we use those products every day in our
lives but we don't know what goes on
behind
where when the children are born in
these plantations they have access to no
citizenship and therefore malaysia does
not provide for any uh access to
education for them itania runs schools
in forests of borneo which as you can
see in this picture are fast
deteriorating and are being taken away
they hire or they rent spaces and
shopping malls
or even at times and stay cases but they
still are able to provide for a great
learning environment for these kids uh
that or at least a pedagogy that they
believe in
so for us it was very clear that these
children who are very who are very much
discarded in the society need a place
which they can call their own a school
which would give them some pride and
dignity and will teach them not only
through the aids but just the
experiences of being in the building and
the surroundings
and the goal was really to make sure
that these children are not left behind
and can be
different than what experiences they've
had as responsible citizens into the
future the site was quite challenging
being close to a river uh which uh
floods every couple of years in fact
recently in may we heard that it flooded
almost two feet and the entire site was
underwater as well and we went around
and looked in beaufort which is where
the straw where the school is located to
see how they have been dealing with
these problems in the past and it has
been quite a challenge and for us the
obvious thing became that the school had
to be lifted up so imagine if this is
the site to the school which often gets
flooded
as you see with the dots all around them
if the obvious thing for us was to
actually take and dig and create a pond
where we could actually store some water
and create a mound through that water
and that becomes the stepping st uh
stone to get onto the building we also
had access to a couple of shipping
containers that we used to prop up and
keep the costs very very low we had
access to some old wood that we used to
actually build and really used minimal
amount of materials to build the entire
school
and as the school was built
you could see this there was a central
corridor and the classrooms kind of
flanked each side of the corridor the
school was also designed such that it
could be expanded as the school would
expand in the future all the same
modules could be taken up and built
elsewhere as itania had ambitious plans
to run many many schools
the the school uh therefore had access
to uh solar panels uh on top it harvests
its rain water cleans its own sewage and
in fact as you would see later in the
pictures it also grows its own food here
is a short video of the school and i
remember going there about a year and a
half ago and speaking to some children
and one of the parents came to me and
mentioned to me that now our children
don't want to come back home because
they love studying in the school and
this is really their second home so it's
quite surprising where my own kids don't
want to go to school but the the
environment that we've created has
allowed students to take pride and spend
more and more time into the school the
space also allows for flexibility for
people to actually come forward and
and make the space their own at times
the classrooms become workshop areas or
they can become like conference areas
where the students can hold these
conferences
at times the corridors become like play
areas for the kids and the trees become
the classrooms as well
but the point really is that we have not
provided for any flexibility into the
school and it really belongs to the to
the parents where you can see they've
actually acquired some of the land on
the side and they grow their own food
and then they set up little shops for
children to eat in between as well and
then it's all it's all of course about
studies and at the same time about play
as well so in conclusion i think itania
is an example where with less resources
our goal is to provide the maximum for
the children and like i said to never
ever design poorly for the poor thank
you
thank you for that mr prasud kumar
our next speaker is architect siachi
huang chief executive officer of dp
architects he is a firm believer in a
people-centric and participatory design
process and is actively involved in the
engagement of various communities to
achieve strategic and synergistic design
outcomes in dp architects projects
today he will share about good luck
makan a delightful remake of the senior
activity center that brings seniors
together using the common language of
food architecture over to you
thank you audrey so good afternoon
friends ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure for me to present to you today
how we aspire to create a better world
by design and this is really true a
special project for ours name good life
so this project is a response to the
challenge of the silver tsunami of an
aging landscape so singapore
some may know as one of the most rapidly
aging populations in the world
maybe bad news for some of us in this
room in 2000
2030 one in four of us will be
age 65 years or more
but more importantly along with this
there's also a rise in the often
forgotten group of state-alone seniors
that will almost double in number
from 72 to 130 000 by 2030 i20302 and
many of these seniors
are susceptible
to
the dangers of being isolated
and suffer from depression and even
unfortunately in some cases
deaths at home so hence the question on
how can design address the psychological
and emotional needs of these vulnerable
seniors becomes a primary
concern here
and through the active programming in
this case
of the agency of food we rethink
the model of care for this agent seniors
so beyond offering meal support
or day care we explore how we can tackle
the existential and emotional needs of
this
true purposeful design and programming
this is some of the statistics of the
project
just to share a clip
and give you a sense of the space so
good life makan is a senior activity
center it's cited in the void deck of a
public housing in the mature residential
estate of marine terrace so our partner
here is a social welfare organization
wanford care
some will know makan is to eat in malay
and fittingly we have this in the center
of the space the kitchen as the nucleus
and daily the stay alone seniors in the
neighborhood gather here and cook for
not just themselves
but also for one another with groceries
brought by themselves or donated by
charities so shifting from the
conventional door to door social aid
these seniors
are invited to cook for each other and
in this case especially those in greater
need and through the ritual of food
preparation eating washing up the spaces
create opportunities for interaction so
the design of good life makan leverages
on the familiar setting of the hdb void
deck so as someone who grew up in a
public housing setting the everyday kind
of a community space here becomes really
special
and the power of design
in place and programming here really
reframes the role of these seniors
from object of charity to the stewards
of our community
and what makes this difference
from the traditional model of care is
instead of volunteers visiting them so
the seniors come down to help themselves
and help others so the design here was
strategic where we engage the seniors to
work with us in the planning of the
spaces here and through this build trust
with them
and also activate that notion of sense
of self-worth
and build this stronger sense of
community over time so porosity is key
in reinforcing this sense of inclusivity
where the center is seamlessly connected
with the surrounding streets so in space
we wanted to retain the porous and open
characteristics of the void deck
that promotes good ventilation daylight
and in outlook so instead
of the typical
gated or
or even glazed up
senior centers we see quite common the
facade of the centers is designed with
an array of
openable full height doors that allows
us to retain that cross ventilation but
more importantly it creates an inviting
age and welcomes
these visitors
and significantly here it blurs the
boundary between the inside and outside
of the centers with the surrounding link
ways which helps to reduce the
marginalization of this demographic
group and in utilizing the space we
wanted to preserve the character and
retain this as a key space for social
interaction and community bonding
internally an array of vibrant colors
and textures add interest to the center
shifting away from the typically muted
palette associated with senior centers
and the rich palette is also deployed in
the internal storage and spatially the
colors are injected to help functionally
to zone the activity centers from
seniors who are also suffering from
mouth dementia so the specially designed
infographics
and signages also further break down
language barrier for seniors from
different race to create a more
inclusive setting for role
[Music]
the needs and aspirations of the
communities are always involving
and in fact
we capitalize on the kovic period
when the center is closed for safety
measure and took the opportunity to
update and refresh the facilities to
reach out to more seniors and wider
community by adding a cafe a day nursing
station and also introduce greenery and
we're also looking at the network of
centers and marine terrace with good
life to see how we can enhance this
setting and capitalize on the power of
network
so small
is beautiful here
the idea of this project though modest
in skill is big in aspiration i wanted
just to end off
uh with the story of uncle louis one of
the stay alone seniors the one in purple
so uncle ruiz checked
that prior to the whole conception of
the project
when the group came to him and asked for
help us to offer help to him his
straight answer was no
when when good life was created he
reached out to him and asked uncle if he
can come down and help
others help himself he said let's do it
so from injecting life to the void deck
to enriching lives of these seniors
through the capacity of design good life
makan reframes the roles of these
seniors reconnect them and empower them
importantly to be active participants of
our community through purposeful
programming and design we can enhance
physical mental and very importantly
psychological
health of not just our seniors but the
larger community
that
thank you
thank you for that architect sierra
chihuan
last but not least our final pda 2020
recipient featured today is the urban
tropical village for seniors kampung
admiralty
architect paul chi is a director for
waha and she leads its design
project team in design execution and
implementation of innovative and
award-winning private and public
projects she will share with us how the
successful integration of programs not
only enables seniors to lead independent
and active lives but also draws in
families friends and the public to
create a vibrant community hub architect
chi over to you please
thank you very much um audrey um
good afternoon everybody i'm presenting
kampong mlt um
the theme of this project is connection
and integration
i'll jump straight to a series of design
diagrams to
explain the layering of the different
programs the site is next to mrt station
and site area is about one hectare
the project brief has four key
components commercial a medical center
community programs and public housing
for the elderly
there are facilities run by different
government agency and co-locating them
at this
strategic location gave rise to
opportunity for co-programming
um
[Music]
our first key move was to put the
supermarket the retail shops and food
center on the ground level by compacting
the commercial footprint over two floors
we freed the ground floor for a tropical
plaza
and our next smoke was to overlay the
large footprint of the medical center
over the plaza this provides shape and
shelter which is crucial for its
usability in the tropics
by lifting the medical center to the mid
layer all weather activities can now
take place in a fully public porous and
pedestrianized plaza below the high
volume also allows natural daylight and
raises through ensuring a high degree of
thermal comfort for people
our next key move then was to overlay
the community use of a quieter nature
such as the child care the elder care
and the puppy housing to the upper layer
and over this we created a new elevated
ground level by introducing a community
sky park where young and all can come
together
this park with the gardens and urban
farms adopts a topographic architectural
language of terraces and hills
and at the foothill of the park we
introduced the apartment blocks of
public housing for elderly the hills
effectively shielded the apartments from
the mrt train once
so instead of standalone programs we
have created a layer integrated
urban village
i'm going to just move on to the actual
building section and some images
to show you what has been built
this is the building section the
basement for
vehicle parking
we move up the next layer the lower
layer comprises two floors
the ground floor is a porous tropical
plaza that brings the community together
and is designed to prioritize pedestrian
circulation through the building to the
train station
the plaza is a bright and breezy double
volume space that serves as a community
living room
it is activated by shops and a food
center on the upper level
we have oculus in the middle that opens
up to the light air and views of the sky
park at the upper levels the plaza now
is a popular social space
and provides daily convenience to
residents
in the middle layer we spread the
medical center over two floors the
footprint covers almost the entire site
and all the internal weighting and
circulation areas are organized around a
center garden courtyard
architecturally it is like an umbrella
sheltering and shading the tropical
plaza below and it is also acting
as a supporting floor for the landscape
above
the rain garden courtyard brings natural
daylight and green into the interiors
which helps to promote healing
and well-being
now the upper layer of the building is a
new elevated ground level for the more
quiet and private community
facilities
so this is um
actually a view out of the window of
your
elderly apartments which looks towards
the sky park
and at this level
child care and senior care as side by
side and also adjacent to landscape
outdoors so these adjacency programs
brings the young and old together
encouraging intergenerational
bonding
and they share the new ground level for
outdoor exercises and playgrounds
and
the idea of locating the urban farm on
the rooftop encourages the elderly to be
active and socialized with others while
taking care of the community farm
but leaves and ramps are provided to
help the persons using wheelchairs
now lastly the housing blocks for the
elderly
in terms of floor plans is eight units
per floor the units are modular and
designed with barrier-free access
we arrange them in pairs with buddy
looks
at shared entrances for enablers to sit
chat and care for each other
this is a view of the housing blocks um
growing as it were out of the sky park
and surrounded by its large landscape
the buddhist notes are actually benches
that were designed to encourage
interaction at the shared entrances of
each pair of apartments
they face each other and main doors
in housing flats are usually kept open
for ventilation in this case it actually
helps to keep watch
over each other
this is my last slide the project was
opened in 2018 and it's
very successful and i'm happy to
see the hdb studying to adapt this
prototype in future towns and with that
thank you
thank you architect g and thank you to
all our recipients for sharing on your
inspiring and delightful projects i'll
now hand the time over to our moderator
architect larry young once again for the
question and answer session please
welcome larry and the recipients
thank you audrey i'm sure all of you are
inspired by their design taught their
design processes and what they have
achieved
in the end
so um we don't have a lot of time but
i'm going to start
directing some questions perhaps to
everybody maybe the first question goes
to bing bing and belinda
perhaps ellen and sito if anybody else
wants to answer by all means
this is a conversation
so design should start with people's
needs
given that communities
often have diverse needs
how can designers and architects
balance these different requirements
to create satisfactory outcomes for
everyone
any takers oh well maybe we can go
yeah so
for us we love to work in this kind of
multi-contextual
settings where there are many different
stakeholders
and we have learned
that
the art of listening and dialogue is so
important
and we use different different tools to
uh to
to get feedback sometimes workshops
using post-it pads and sometimes just
drawings and all sorts of different ways
i think the important thing is that
architecture is a little bit like an
or the act of design is a lot like uh
pulling an orchestra together or maybe
boiling a good uh herbal soup you know
you put all the ingredients and to
figure out the soup and we try not to be
the ingredients but maybe the soup
[Laughter]
actually actually um the the fact that
we don't really need to do the balancing
but i do i do find ourselves um needing
to facilitate the conversations between
the communities because at the end of
the day they are the ones who will be
using the space together and it won't be
us so it's about maintaining again
maintaining their connection with each
other and actually uh honoring what each
one has to say and then um really
answering to their needs
yes i do agree in fact i pick up your
keyword the art of listening your
context must have the odds of listening
otherwise it's going to be challenging
for you
to translate
the uh the brief from the clients
into what they truly want to get in the
end so the act of listening is very
important
so alan and sito do you have your take
or do you also agree
yeah but uh and perhaps you'll take a
different angle and also kind of reframe
your questions that obviously and also
the topic of the discussion impacts
lives right design impact lives more
lives you impact more lives
right and interestingly houses who do
you impact for us a house impact
immediately the household six person
plus domestic helpers and in that
context and also relevant to many young
designers start off with houses small
interiors then does that mean that okay
my work doesn't impact lives
the important thing it would be then how
do we project that how do we do single
family houses that immediately impact
the lives of the family but how how
about lives of others is that the
potential of that which is what we are
very interested in
as we see houses occupies our entire uh
interest in architecture you know
single-family houses from miss van der
rohe's sponsors paths framework rights
falling waters they have impact the
generation of
of of houses and house designers and how
one would live right
and i think that is that something that
we feel through even a single family
house that impact the immediate families
how would that be
the design contributions how could that
be extended how would we be adding to
the conversation and the dialogue of
architectural discourse
that in some way we contribute in our
you know in a bigger discussion or a
deeper discussion that will influence
others and i think the pda is one good
platform that that kind of like verified
that effort than the ambition that we
have yeah
wonderful
at least we know that
pda is the uh
it's something that everybody can look
towards through towards and also
something that you can
uh finally motivate all of you to do
even better
now um let me direct uh the next
question to
zlin and prashunt
both ethenia itania green school and
sparkle thoughts
large preschool focus on creating an
experiential
learning
experience
as well as play outside the classrooms
what are the design elements
that led to this common objective
and what can it be said about the future
of educational facilities for young
children
person
fine by
five so
yeah larry thanks thanks for the
question i think yeah yeah all right
you're right i think the focus of early
childhood pedagogy has shifted from
uh inside classroom thinking to more of
outdoor learning
i i think that's a that's a great trend
because um as i mentioned earlier when
the kids are so young um they don't
learn from reading abcs they learn from
experiential
experience experiencing the the nature
the wind the rain by touching tactile
and
what is a greater teacher than nature in
a way so
they learn more from from f uh doing
farming touching the soy and playing
platforms even um so so that that at the
young age these memories really will
imprint themselves and their minds and
um also i i suppose uh the other benefit
from getting from that is like they will
learn to appreciate nature when they
grow up and it will manifest in
in other ways respecting the environment
for example and
it will give rise to a new trend of
thinking hopefully and
uh so so that that is um yeah what i
have to say about that so i i think it
is really a good trend and um ecda early
childhood development agency is really
pushing this approach for
subsequent child cares from now on
for sure i agree with you because if you
want to learn anything you need
experiential learning is definitely
trump over spoon feed
the the children i remember when i was
in australia they were saying that
in many of the cities it's a bit more
challenging for them to do what you say
experiential learning but in australia
if you want to know about a cow gold
milk account in that sense you know what
i mean so actually doing the actual
action
portion you have something else to add
on
because yours is a very interesting
school
yeah i want to make maybe two comments
firstly i think for italian school
it wasn't about creating an outdoor
environment for experience right for us
the building is part of the landscape
and it allows the flexibility where the
classrooms become the playground or the
dance studio or the theater studio and
the outside becomes a classroom if it's
not raining or if it's not too hot
so the entire site is actually the
outside and inside and i i've actually
observed the teachers using it that way
as well
so i think our perspective was uh was
really to push the boundaries on on
really creating a seamless environment
for the kids the teachers and the
parents uh to be able to come together
and experience the school
uh on your point regarding uh the future
of education i think uh uh we all
understand and we all believe that
experiential learning is the way to go
and and and what yin just mentioned
about
playing in sand and stuff is mentioned
but if you look at the environment
around us we become so perfectionist and
so protective that we actually in
reality do not want to provide that
environment right we see astroturf in
school uh we see limited time that
people get spent outside and even the
experiential learning is often on ipad
and use of technology
and it's become an eight
and it's not about self-learning so i
think the goal for future should be more
giving the freedom and really shake off
all these
inhibitions that we have in terms of
creating an environment which is
constructed every time and let the
nature and children build their own
environment and not be so structured and
so fearful
all the time and i don't think we are
moving in that direction but i would
like us to move in that direction
slowly and steadily i'm sure i do
believe the world is the playground so
there's lots to learn in that thank you
i uh now move on to
pearl and jihuang
kampung emerity as an integrated public
housing development for seniors
it's a very good prototype for cities
with aging societies
good life makan
is a senior activity center
also known for its groundbreaking design
concept and successful prototype to
purposefully
re-integrate stay alone elderly back
into the community
so what are the key challenges
when designing for seniors from
different backgrounds
for both of you
ladies first huh
yes thank you
um
i i think uh there is there's already
tools to help us uh navigate how to
design inclusively for people with
different uh abilities so when you say
different you know
seniors probably uh for example
universal design guides and and so on
they are very good good tools to help us
uh but
i want to also uh
talk about uh
another um face to the question which is
uh in the course of designing the
project actually the the whole project
team was thinking about the aging issues
um and this came up because we we always
in our society or in singapore we
probably look to take care of
elderlies when they are very sick and
very old
so this project actually caused us to
think about
uh what happens before they grow old and
weak
we are doing something before they're
growing old and weak
so um
that's why there was a lot of
community spaces that links them there
is a lot of thinking about how to
co-program uh the young and the old
together yeah so it's to really help
the elderly uh
grow independently and socially also
more connected
okay
aging gracefully in place yeah in a way
all right uh chihuan
yeah so uh thanks just really to add on
to first point
uh i think the obvious challenge with
regards to designing for seniors as per
share
i think fundamental rules of universal
design friendly for
not just seniors but people of all
ability or disability i think but the
very important part is this idea of not
just being attractive but familiarity i
think is actually very key for some of
these seniors and i must applaud uh pda
not just because you are all my friends
right and the agencies here but
clustering these projects together like
uh because when i looked at the
challenges of kampung and reality and
good life makan
but or you can almost draw parallel but
very connected well kampong mrt is like
a hub where uh good life is like a spoke
and this is a big building note while
the other works as a network one is
newly created
and the other is integrating with
existing fabric but it's very important
that the two work as an entire ecosystem
of care for the seniors because the
whole idea is not about looking at one
versus the other in fact it's very
important that one works very well with
the other
so that we can tackle and address
challenges that say
one institution cannot kind of fulfill
in the case of good life because it's
not about material and physical needs
because they are already staying at the
rental blocks right above it's actually
really moving into that um
emotional and psychological needs
and then it's funny that bing bing
belinda
last week we just talked about the
muscle
needs a hierarchy of needs and here it's
actually
not just restoring the seniors about
these aspects of uh way before or beyond
basic not about even self-actualization
because this is pushing to the
self-transcendence needs because they
are helping others it's beyond yourself
and enhanced from there
you empower and restore
that key part of self-worth for for the
seniors and in that sense that was uh
really i would say is the essence but
one very important part is i think as
seniors when i'm imagining i'm growing
old i also don't want the
the whole brand of aging to be over
institutionalized
because sometimes it is a problem i
think this whole state of normalcy like
aging is part of our natural landscape
then we see kids from sparkle thoughts
in nature setting at this school uh
school is it's so critical that we have
more blend rather than compartmentalize
or institutionalize them yeah these are
my thoughts
yes thank you i
totally agree with you in fact
for for most of you a lot of ways of
achieving a creative solution it's more
a holistic and integrated approach
in some of you that said now we have
about 600 attendees today
and maybe i should open up the some
questions
um to those attendees
um let's see
um i should say answer live right answer
live
okay
uh i have this
let me see oh the first question is
the first question is not there already
okay maybe uh the next question
architecture once designed to utilize
and activate the space and the void deck
of our hdb is very
edifying for our spaces and the lives of
the users should we encourage the
authority to roll this concept out to
further optimize the space even more
so for the spaces available and suitable
of course
anyone want to
add on
perhaps uh
jihan you have the experience so what do
you think
yeah didn't want to hop the mic
but i think as i said earlier
uh avoid that is a very
essential and integral part of our
public housing landscape so it's a space
that's very special in fact
not just about such a senior activity
center but the whole
queue
how we curate this space
to also retain its core characteristics
of being open
porous
is is very very critical and and how do
we also ensure
we evolve the design or rather than the
non-design of void decks
also becomes a key uh i would say design
challenge for many of the friends and uh
here and online
so that it continues to add value and
add richness in the way we look at
our homes and living environment
yeah i'll just probably
stop there first
yeah
any other addition from anyone
but i would say generally even hdbs are
also engaging the community themselves
and even do have programs
to ask the community what do they want
to do with their spaces around them so i
think
this is something that is already
ongoing
and and that's why even and parks has
the what you call
uh
community bloom programs where there's
so many now more than a thousands of the
community gardens um especially those
among the hdb flats so a lot of things
are in some way
flexible it's a matter of engagement and
what's best
for the people community in that region
uh let me
post another questions from the
the
public
which is small contemporary
i would like to hear from the panel on
their thoughts about how coveted 19 has
affected the way they design buildings
and internal spaces
given that we are in the new norm
should design be drawn to suit these or
be done in the hope that things will
return to the way they will
well it's an interesting question which
is very contemporary we are all now in
the heightened alert
and i'm sure it affects many of you in
your
work in your social life and so
anyone want to attempt to add yes
presume you want to say something yeah i
think in our case
we are currently building some houses in
the philippines
and we see that the the fact that the
work from home
is become quite normal
and the ability to interact and work
through the internet
is really creating a leveling level
playing field
where you can be in any part in a remote
part of the world and you could have
similar opportunities to being like in a
big city and we think that when we work
in very remote and difficult communities
with very limited opportunities uh the
covet 19 is creating a new wave which we
would want to tap onto and ensure that
the people that we work with have can
take the
advantage of it so some of the houses we
are designing we are ensuring that we we
work with some internet community
providers for good internet facilities
their work from home facilities
while we do our create continuing to
create public spaces as well because we
do think i mean at the end of the day
some things will go back to normal but i
think from a world education standpoint
we are addressing to those changes to
create new opportunities
yeah
yeah uh add on for for us i think uh we
have uh been rethinking how we build
complexity and complex systems so uh
rather than
looking you know just purely as a
big uh project we tend to look at them
in parts that come together to form a
whole so very much having an ecological
uh
um
function so if let's say we are
designing a big hall we will try to make
small little holes that could be
separated or could be combined together
so that that level of um flexibility uh
where you can connect and as well as
separate makes it a lot more resilient
than just a typical hierarchy
yeah i think if i just add to that right
i hear what uh what you're saying pretty
soon and i actually agree with it that
that where there is a new norm and then
we are just getting so used to being
talking to yourself in this sort of
technological platform but i think at
the end of the day we are still created
to have a relationship a face-to-face
relationship so rather than then be
overly focused on a disease um that is
how do we really maximize um that kind
of face to face and opportunities to
come together um
in in the new design as well
yeah i agree there is really no right or
no wrong to
to these answers to these questions
what is more important is continuing
conversations because i read the
articles there are two schools taught
one school says that oh okay because we
have been working from home now they
they probably
do not need
more offices and and all that so
therefore lots of changes would would be
impacted on the environment and the
other school i've taught is that
just like what belinda says i mean
you're working at home on your own but
human beings are generally gregarious in
nature and you need to meet up you need
to socialize and all that so
well who is right who's wrong there are
these two articles two schools of
thought are from many many different
people
so i think what's important is for all
of us as designers to get together and
continue the conversation i think that
is very important yes
anyone else want to add add-on
maybe
i mean coming from the experience of
designing a few child cares you know um
i shared upon this idea of flex design
flexibility as well
and that was a small thing like a you
know a
hamper mouth but
um those lessons are actually taken on
and uh in the subsequent child cares
that we are designing actually we are
told to seriously look into the ideas of
flexibility alternate entrances
and also so that we can really pivot
from
a full-on
mode where all the students come or
the
uh when something happens um
part of them come so i i think i agree
with um belinda that at larry so that uh
you know humans are social creatures we
will certainly want to meet face to face
and in my in my
uh
example you know that
the children really want to play with
their friends and um
doing it virtually it just doesn't
uh it's just not there so we were
moving forward architects still need to
design for places of community and
congregation but
um
we have to design in
in mind of the alternate modes
and um flexibility so that the
architecture itself can really adapt to
circumstances when it happens
that there's a yeah
okay thank you and we hope this all of
you as
top designers should continue this
conversation because
we will be probably looking and
discussing more on post covet new normal
so what is considered the new normal
spaces i think sia can actually even
organize lots of debates on this because
it is very interesting project
i have a comment from chi kian
he says that the void deck did not start
as office void in his early years
there were mini
oh hang on first this suddenly
goes off somewhere
they were
it just disappeared from my screen they
were mini
what do you call mama shops libraries
and all that but actually if you if you
look at um
um that is there's a lot i was from htv
for quite a while there were many
reasons why void decks were created one
of the more important reason is that
white deck
is void and it's very unique to
singapore public housing hdb flag i
think not many places else have this and
when you have the void that it's very
useful
it can be used in terms of emergency or
even non-emergency
to be converted to spaces like the good
life makan or something else so it
supplements
very very immediately
and that's why in hdb
in hdb planning the planning or the of
the hdb flat is a checker box so there
are reserve side in between should there
be a need somewhere a reserved site can
also be activated so it's the same
principle
um
let me see
okay maybe this is more devoted to pearl
maybe pearl can just a quick summary
government agency has many committees
and thus has many voices can walk share
the experience navigating them and
creating this wonderful project
it's a very good question actually the
this project we worked with seven
agencies and um in
we we had a very um uh strong steering
committee work i mean
the project team
and the clients team um
i think what is uh very very useful and
critical to to the success is that uh
there is a principle that everybody uh
agrees on which is to
that the whole is better than the parts
because agencies bring their their their
organizational excellencies to the table
but really you need to be able to
tell them to have this a vision a whole
vision that that rises above individual
uh organization excellences yeah so i
think that's very important to to
remember as a principle
yeah of driving the project
okay thank you i'm very mindful of the
time uh there was one comment i think
which i think prussian you have uh uh uh
answered who funds the brilliant brics
project do you have to raise fund i
think russian you mentioned billion
brics projects are donor funded
yes we have to raise funds okay
all right um
there's one or two more also quite
related to what us uh
uh pearl let me check whether it is
anymore
this is a very interesting one for years
i think many of us whether urban
designer urban planners or architects
are always trying to do
maybe we we can just say a few words as
uh the last input for today's forum
i anonymous it says how can the true
kampong spirits
be sustained
and enhanced in the built environment by
future designers
even if we don't have any check away for
this just bear the questions and uh
think about it all the time
how does anybody want to say about
kampung spirit
um i kind of want to say something
sure yeah so um as he is linked to a
series of questions including chikan's
comment about the void deck i mean we
have liang talking about chihuahuan's
design and whether the agencies should
encourage it and then yeah chicken
talking about what the original void
deck is actually used for it's a mini
library it's it's everything so it's
like a village square so to speak so i
think um the kampong spirit can only
come in if it is
if if we can encourage so whether it's
the agencies that does it or or
developers that does it uh we need to
remove some of the silos we need to
remove this space is for the elderly and
that space is for the child care we need
to break these boundaries and of course
architecturally we can do that um we see
we see uh chihuahuan doing that breaking
the porosity we see
walha doing that we see pearl doing that
but but at the end of the day there is
also the software the thinking behind
new pedagogies that need to come in it
shouldn't be the kids singing to the
elderly but can there be a program
where both are actually um you know they
can all be one safe space and supported
together so the whole village square has
to happen
okay any other taker because this is a
topic
that
i don't think
in the modernization
of singapore or urbanization of
singapore
uh i won't say we have completely lost
the kampung spirit
but
definitely there are opportunities where
we need to think about it to bring back
what is known as kampung spirit
i lived in a camp long before but you
see the difference between in living in
a kampong as you walk the path you will
come to every different uh houses you
walk past them and you say hello to them
and you get to know them better and they
don't lock the door the doors are always
open
so that is a bit different so when hdb
in the 80s created what we call
courtyard in the sky
the new generation flags
where you have six
to eight
units sharing
a
big common corridor with bigger spaces
it's actually meant to create spaces
for interaction
but actually the lift lobby is one of
the best places to
to create for interaction so
um we have not successfully
bring the spirit kampung spirit into the
new flats but there are always
many areas that i think we can look at
it uh cert to to some success but this
is a question which i think all
designers will
probably especially when you talk about
designing for community so this is one
that we all have to take away with us
and think about it
any last intake before we uh i hand over
to audrey
you know uh larry writer
answered that come from question yes one
of us had the benefit of experiencing it
with my uncle at that
pig farm and i mean i used to at least
remember but i think more and more so
it's very important that we
define this new idea of a communal
living because soon our kids
who do not have this connection this
word kampong will be very foreign you'll
be so abstract and in fact it is really
talking about this idea of as you said
sense of community but more importantly
this idea of trust and relationship
because you know the space has no gate
and then they talk about you know a
whole village raising up a child that's
that idea of collective living
and in fact it is for us again as a
possibly a design
question of how can we establish this
new idea of communal living as we move
forward towards the future and create
maybe another term in itself and
continue to
progress this concept of us coming
together
as a larger community
thanks gwang i think the conversation
has to continue
but definitely uh for warhawks project
it's called kampung empirici i think
that is
an attempt to really bring the community
together so perhaps we can have more
kampung elsewhere a modern kampung just
like the kampung admiralties
okay there's no other take i like to uh
i think we way past the time it's such
an interesting
conversation
dialogue i'd like to personally thank
you all the pda recipients and once
again
my heartiest congratulations to all the
winners the pinnacles of all design
awards with that i'll hand over to
audrey audrey over to you
thanks so much for that larry and all
our recipients for sharing your
experience with our audience
to our guests we most definitely hope to
see you again next week on the 12th of
august for part two of the president's
design award recipients forum where five
of the recipients will share how their
designs have sparked transformation in
the country community and economy
please scan the qr code for the
registration link
we'd also appreciate it if you could
complete a short survey for this webinar
to help us improve on our future
programs please scan the qr code for the
survey forms
for those of you who would like to apply
for cpd points please also scan the same
qr code you see on the left of the
screen and submit your particulars by
today
give you a minute to get that started
[Music]
if you would like to find out a little
bit more about the various upcoming
programs the national design center has
lined up do also scan the qr code that
you see on the screen right now and if
you'd like to find out more about the
recipients please visit our website
pda.designsingapore.org
that's pda.designsingapore.org
and with that we will be ending the
session for today thank you all once
again to all of our speakers and to all
of you for choosing to spend your
wednesday afternoon with us my name is
audrey have a great evening ahead bye
[Music]